Wow
ne vieillit jamais hé Tony ici regarde
ce triomphe technologique imposant tu
sais au moins nous pensons à l'unité l'unité
malheureusement est quelque chose qui manque dans l'
équipage des Avengers ces derniers temps alors j'ai pensé que je
demanderais conseil et la Dame de Fer vous-même
mais vous ne pouvez pas  viens les mains vides tu sais
sinon je ne serais pas un
gentleman de fer mais je pense que c'est la
ville lumière
peut-être que ça ne la dérangerait pas si je prends
un peu le troupeau avec ses ampoules hey hon
commençons avec du noir de base
ouais ouais blues  dans sa couleur chaude pour le
printemps
Oh
maintenant elle me parle à quoi pense-t-elle d'
accord d'accord hé hé
je vais poser mon téléphone tu me montres fille
ce que ah tu dois te moquer de moi
casquette d'équipe je veux dire comment tu reviens
de  que tu portes un toast
à tes visages